bonjour à tous et bon soir jean claude
mailly merci d'être avec nous au
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
vous êtes invité de preuves par 3 après
l'elysée ou françois hollande lui même
vous avez invité pour son investiture
vous bien sûr et les autres responsables
syndicaux aux manières pour le nouveau
président de manifester son attachement
au dialogue social occasion bien sûr que
vous n'avez pas l'intention de laisser
passer les revendications sont déjà là
depuis plusieurs mois sur à la fois les
retraites sur les salaires sur le smic
et cetera on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec bruno francheski de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindra avec notamment les
questions des téléspectateurs qui
peuvent réagir et donc intervenir durant
cette émission par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque de notre
partenaire orange
jean claude mailly donc vous avez foulé
le tapis de l'elysée en ce jour j est ce
déjà de bonne augure pour vous écoutez
moi je crois que le président de la
république a voulu me l'a dit d'ailleurs
dans son discours montré l'intérêt qu'il
portait au dialogue social la démocratie
au respect des interlocuteurs sociaux
bon de ce point de vue là sur la méthode
ça démarre pas trop mal après on verra
sur on verra sur les dossiers et sur les
ce point là il ya un deuxième point qui
m'apparaît important dans ce qu'il a dit
ce matin si jaurès sur le mode de
fonctionnement et la méthode c'est
qu'apparemment on aura un gouvernement
qui gouverne
donc tous dessinés va pas l'elysée après
on va voir dans les salles est important
pour vous d'être
à l'elysée on ne cessa de ces
investitures oui c'est un c'est un
caractère républicain est comme quand on
va au feu c'est prestigieux républicain
et l'absence de bernard thibault est
regrettable est ce que vous la comprenez
ça c'est à lui qu'il faut poser la
question est votre jugement
il est commode en nous battant défi ce
qu'il veut voilà ça c'est moi j'étais là
d'autres étaient là bon il était un
empêchement la cgt étaient représentées
lui n'était pas là mais par son leader
principal est ce que vous êtes heureux
de l'alternance se pose pas en termes
mais c'est pas en séparant terme en tant
que secrétaire général de fo s'est pas
en terme d' être heureux ou pas heureux
bon c'est vrai que ces dernières
semaines il ya eu beaucoup de critiques
sur les syndicats au les corps
intermédiaires etc
ça partait un peu dans tous les sens et
ça pose un moment donné des problèmes de
démocratie
ceci étant il ya la méthode la nature
des relations qu'on peut avoir avec un
gouvernement ou un président de la
république ça c'est une chose mais après
il ya tous les dossiers qui vont arriver
savais pas trop où on va les aborder au
cours de cette émission vous dites que
françois hollande a annoncé qu'il y aura
donc un gouvernement qui gouverne
ça n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
pour vous l'interlocuteur à banneux ces
cinq dernières années l'essentiel des
décisions se prenaient à l'elysée
s'étend dans les faits quoi je bon je ne
dis pas que le premier ministre ne
faisait rien mais beaucoup de décisions
beaucoup de gros dossiers se traiter
directement directement à l'elysée ce
qui pose des pas mal de problèmes
d'avoir on peut pas tout traiter dans un
seul lieu
quelles que soient les personnes en
responsabilité et un deuxième problème
qui dort démocratique quand vous avez un
conflit avec un gouvernement ce qui
arrive régulièrement en face de vous si
vous avez un premier ministre qui est
responsable devant le parlement
si on gagne le conflit rappelez-vous le
cpe le prémice peut servir de fusible
alors en face de vous oui mais qu'en
face de vous vous avez un président de
la république élu pour cinq ans a durci
obligatoirement les conflits c'est un
problème de fonctionnement
vous promettez un sort enviable à jean
marc canon
j'en sais rien ça on verra écoutez moi
je le rôle de fusible occasion dans la
clé dans la 5ème constitution quoi qu'on
puisse en penser par ailleurs ça souvent
fonctionné fonctionné comme ça après ça
on verra bien
l usage qu elle l comme moi comment
est-ce que vous jugez le profil social
du nouveau premier ministre
c'est quelqu'un que je connais que j'ai
eu l'occasion de rencontrer pas mal de
fois à la fois parce qu'il était
président du groupe parlementaire et on
était auditionné régulièrement ou à
nantes puisqu'il est il est maire de
nantes c'est quelqu'un d'ouvert
c'est quelqu'un qui a la grosse tête ça
c'est vrai de simple quelqu'un qui
dialoguent qui dialoguent facilement
maintenant la tâche va pas être facile
pour lui comme pour d'autres et on verra
comme premier ministre ce que ça donne
vous lui faites confiance à côté moi je
ne porte pas d'à priori je fais
confiance
voilà après savez c'est dans les
relations après il ya des choses qui
sont décidés après il ya la confiance ça
s'improvise pas c'est aussi dans la
relation on voit si on peut se parler
franchement qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord
et ça on verra dans les mois à venir
très bientôt les cas il n'y a pas d'état
de grâce le nom le temps des illusions
et est passé il appartient aux souvenirs
c'est pas le temps des illusions c'est
le contexte qui veut qu'il n'y ait pas
d'état de grâce
regardez d'ailleurs le président est
tout de suite parti à berlin donc sur un
dossier un des gros dossiers ou des
semaines à venir qui démarre ce soir
c'est sûr renégociation par
renégociation des traités européens mais
c'est la manière dont on sortira du
dossier opèrent ça va conditionner aussi
ce qui va se passer en france et dans
les autres pays donc c'est le contexte
qui fait qu'il n'ya pas d'état de grâce
à cette situation qui n'est pas terminé
avec les élèves à économiques sociales
dont un signe a pas d'état de grâce à ce
qu'au moins vous pouvez garantir au
gouvernement pendant quelques mois voire
plus une trêve sociale bien sans moi je
peux rien garantir du tout ça n'est pas
non mais comment voulez vous que je
garantis moi je fais pas des chèques en
blanc je vais pas non plus dire on va
mobiliser ça dépend de la manière dont
les dossiers seront traités ce qui se
passera dans l'est dans les semaines et
les mois à venir rien et écrit par
avance je pense qu'il faut un dialogue
comme on dit associé à une concertation
qui soit
régulière qu'on puisse je suppose que
dès que le gouvernement sera formé
demain on aura des contacts assez rapide
et après on verra au fur et à mesure des
dossiers on savait rien de peut être
programmé pour un an de 3 ans vous
reconnaissez que la réponse aux
frustrations parfois la colère sociale
ne sont pas faciles en raison de cette
crise que vous évoquez vous mais moi les
gens ne sont pas stupides ils savent
tout le monde sait bien que demain à pas
raser gratis ça c'est évident qu est ce
que sam hodder les revendications non il
ya des attentes en même temps et il ya
des attentes en matière de pouvoir
d'achat il ya des attentes en matière
d'emploi et des attentes en matière de
service public
il ya des attentes en matière de justice
sociale et fiscale
voilà c'est de la nature de ces réponses
c'est pas un dossier
c'est un ensemble qui va être abordée
alors six semaines avant on va le voir
un peu plus tard dans le détail mais
certains ont déjà agité la menace d'un
troisième tour social dans la rue est ce
que vous êtes de ceux-là
non je ne renonce à écouter vous savez
ça c'est comme les automne chaud les 3e
tour cette troisième tour j'aime pas
cette formule d'ailleurs ça laisse
entendre que et après les élections il
ya autre chose
ah non moi je mais jeudi bien jeudi non
je n'en sais rien franchement le
troisième tour social ont donné le
principe oui pourquoi voulez-vous que
aujourd'hui je dis voilà il va y avoir
un troisième tour social ça voudrait
dire que sur tel ou tel dossier voilà ce
que le gouvernement va décider on sera
pas d'accord on n'en sait rien pour le
moment donc qu'on va être pragmatique
également on a nos positions on les a
expliquées avant la campagne pendant la
campagne et on verra ensuite comment les
choses se pinçant voilà jean luc
mélenchon en tous les cas lui a dit
qu'il fallait qu'il faudrait sans doute
entendre le message de la rue s'il
s'exprime dans les semaines qui viennent
et il a adressé une lettre aujourd'hui à
jean marc ayrault il l'appelle à stopper
l'hémorragie industrielle par la loi
est-ce que les solutions de jean luc
mélenchon vous paraissent crédibles dans
le contexte actuel elle cite sa bande
d'entreprises emblématiques rc d'orbital
aulnay le site de l'esa encore où les
fralib ou encore petroplus mais enfin
vous a pas échappé comme à moi que lui
comme d'autres sans campagne électorale
pour les législatives donc laissons leur
leurs responsabilités en campagne
électorale
on règle pas tout par la loi bien
entendu qu'il va falloir intervenir sur
la question des licenciements il ya
différentes manières de régler le
dossier suffit pas de dire il faut
interdire les licenciements point barre
comment on fait donc c'est pas aussi
simple que ça mais bon il ya en campagne
électorale jean grey cloche donc voila
vous l'envoyer à sa campagne électorale
à hénin-beaumont quand il dit qu'il faut
prendre des décisions tout de suite sans
attendre par décret pour interdire
certains licenciements
vous ne suivez pas annoncé que je veux
dire c'est une déclaration il a fait une
lettre qui est une lettre de caractère
politique en même temps même s'il vient
sur le terrain le terrain un peu sociale
voire syndicale parfois on veut pas
toujours très nettement la distinction
mais sur certains dossiers on peut
intervenir c'est vrai que des décisions
par décret pas besoin d'attendre que le
parlement au soir unis puisque ça peut
être des décisions par décret mais
certaines des décisions en la matière
passeront obligatoirement par la loi
est-ce qu'on peut consulter
est ce qu'il est ce que l'on doit
consulter les élus du personnel et leur
accorder un certain droit de veto en cas
de fermeture ou de délocalisation de
l'entreprise consultation propositions
de jean-luc mélenchon et d'une autre
organisation syndicale non nous avons
toujours été opposé au droit d'accord
pourquoi parce que si vous avez un droit
de veto sur l'investissement vous êtes
ans c'est comme quand vous donner une
consigne de vote en direct vous êtes
d'une certaine manière en cogestion
c'est donc c'est pas de la
responsabilité syndicale maintenant
qu'il faille améliorer les procédures de
consultation les droits d'un verte etc
tout ça bien entendu mais le droit de
veto nous n'y sommes pas favorables très
bien quelle est la première réforme qui
vous semble nécessaire aujourd'hui en
france pour affronter la crise je pense
que le ce que j c'est l'heure de la
question européenne va être clé alors on
a appris tout à l'heure que l'avion de
françois hollande a dû rebrousser chemin
et manifestement il rentre sur paris car
il a été touché par la foudre il a
décollé tout à l'heure de villacoublay
je vous donnerai la gestion est bon je
pense que tout va bien on l'espère en
tous les cas pour tous les occupants de
l'appareil
d'accord oui mais bon donc je savais pas
mais la question européenne va être clé
va y avoir la question de l'emploi est
la question du service lui je pense pas
qu'ils aient un dossier le dossier qui
risque de venir le plus rapidement
c'est de la responsabilité du candidat
maintenant présidence et le dossier des
retraites parce que je suis un décor
emparer et donc mais je crois qu'il faut
jouer sur plusieurs leviers il n'y a pas
un levier ya l'emploi et le pouvoir
d'achat il ya la question des retraites
mais la question européenne et la
question industrielle et les services
publics voilà j'avais la compétitivité
des entreprises et les dépenses
publiques gens peuvent varier mais moi
je vais levier ces français là qui sont
souvent mais rien de ce que vous a pas
échappé que y compris de formation
économique je suis pas libéral ouais
donc la réduction des dépenses publiques
on a vu ce que ça a donné ces dernières
années je ne pense pas en plus qu'on
sortira de la crise en appliquant les
recettes qui nous envoyer dans le mur
à savoir les recettes libérales son plan
économique du terme réduction des
dépenses on a quand même tué des
services publics ces dernières années il
y à moi de nous on demande d'ailleurs si
hollande s'y était engagé pendant la
campagne avoir un arrêt de la révision
générale des politiques publiques pardon
et nous demandons une véritable
évaluation sur l'état du service public
donc si on commence à lire il faut
réduire les dépenses publiques nous
avons autant vous oppose l'audit sur les
sur les comptes publics alors attendez
vous savez comme moi que un endettement
par rapport à un produit intérieur brut
c'est une division alors vous pouvez
aussi réduire l'endettement en
augmentant la croissance et le produit
intérieur brut donc voilà donc tout ça
se disent oh les gars vous avez vu ce
sondage dans les échos qui indique que
les français sont prêts à des coupes
supplémentaires dans les dépenses
publiques c'est le moyen qu'il met en
premier pour favoriser la croissance à
et ils choisissent celui là c'est
toujours répondre % selon un sondage
opinionway oui deux choses d'abord c'est
c'est toujours vous avez le sentiment
quand on répond ça que vous n'êtes pas
concerné un premier élément
deuxième élément dans le même sondage il
y avait des éléments intéressants
également comme quoi
parce que j'ai eu l'occasion de le voir
ce stage que la dernière des dernières
périodes ce sont surtout les
actionnaires qui ont bénéficié de la
situation économique à 49%
donc je préfère relever cet élément a
bien justement l'argent versé sous forme
de dividende cette année devrait
profiter aux salariés un peu plus
nombreux que l'an dernier dit on avec la
fameuse prime dividende qui avait été
instaurée par le précédent gouvernement
vous allez pouvoir en dire un mot dans
un instant avec donc bruno franceschi de
l' agence france presse qui nous rejoint
pour évoquer donc l'aménagement de la
réforme de la retraite n'est puis le
coup de pouce au smic et au smic qui
sont donc volé deux décisions les plus
attendus par vous même vous nous l'avez
dit les syndicats donc mettre la
pression mais le rétablissement à 60 ans
à ne sera pas pour tout le monde comme
nous le rappelle marie vraiment il avait
promis de revenir dessus
les syndicats peinent françois hollande
élu se rappelle à son bon souvenir dans
le collimateur des organisations
syndicales la réforme des retraites
adoptée en 2010 candidat françois
hollande s'est montré prudent
promettant une retraite à taux plein à
60 ans pour ceux ayant commencé à
travailler à 18 ans ayant cotisé 41 ans
une incertitude demeure cependant pour
le calcul de ces quarante et une années
doit-on prendre en compte les trimestre
effectivement cotisé ou simplement
valider depuis la réforme de 2010 on ne
compte que les trimestre effectivement
cotisé ce qui est pénalisant pour les
chômeurs les personnes qui ont été
chômeur ou pour les femmes qui ont
validé dès trimestre simplement parce
qu'elles ont élevé des enfants et donc
il ya un flou sur la mesure qui sera
effectivement prises qui peut être très
généreuse ou moins généreuse mais
françois hollande et son futur
gouvernement
auront-ils les moyens d'être généreux et
la marge d'erreur est très faible
ce qu'on donnera aux seins ou prendra
aux autres meilleurs a pas moyen
on va augmenter un peu les cotisations
des actifs ne veut pas trop faire porter
sur les actifs puisque le nombre
d'actifs va être de moins en moins
important par rapport au nombre de
retraités
autre promesse du candidat remettre tout
le monde à la table des discussions en
2013 en fait pas vraiment de choix
les prévisions de financement de
réforme de 2010 tablait sur des
estimations bien trop optimiste du coup
dès 2013 les retraites ne sont plus
financés actuellement les régimes de
retraite ont un déficit de l'ordre de 8
milliards d'euros qui provient du fait
que naturellement la france n'a pas
récupéré l'activité perdue depuis la
crise bien avant même le la réforme
envisagée par ce nouveau président on
savait que les clips des retraites
n'était pas n'étaient pas assurés
l'horizon 2018 et qu'il fallait en 2013
remettent les questions sur la table et
on sait très bien qu'on a fait qu'une
réforme est jusqu'ici donc toute façon
il faut tout remettre à plat et
notamment posé la question du système de
retraite à points chantier considérable
qui attend le nouveau président et son
équipe
françois hollande candidat du consensus
sera-t-il imposer un compromis entre le
désir des syndicats et les contraintes
financières
bruno franceschi de l' agence
france-presse
c'est avec nous alors que l'avion de
françois hollande semble repartie cette
fois vers berlin donc il avait dû dans
un premier temps faire demi-tour
apparemment il a été touché par la
foudre
c'est vrai que c'était une journée qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui pour le
président investi entre inverse
et puis éclaircies alors bruno vous
allez rentrer sans doute très très vite
dans vif du sujet d'ailleurs
probablement avec quelques alliés
objectifs comme la cgt puisque vous vous
allez prendre vous allez parler retraite
très vite avec le président ou le
premier ministre vous avez sûrement
parler smig également la retraite on
voit bien que tout le monde n'est pas
exactement sur la même longueur d'onde
on voit bien que vous même vous avez dit
plusieurs fois que vous vouliez il
retraite à 60 ans assure la base dreux
de trimestres cotisés et validées alors
que d'enfoncer pas exactement ce que
souhaite le premier ministre et le
président quant au smic c'est vrai que
là aussi un coup de pouce ou le le
président souhaite un coup de pouce mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous un
coup de pouce sur les retraites d'abord
je rappelle d'ailleurs que quand il
était dans l'opposition notamment
pendant le conflit à que nous avons eues
avec le gouvernement en 2010 le parti
socialiste était pour la retraite à 60
ans même si les bouger d'autres critères
première union deuxième élément là le
candidat a pris un engagement de faire
paraître un décret donc ça peut être
effectivement rapide pour permettre dans
ce qu'on appelle les carrières longues
pour aller vite aux gens qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt de pouvoir
partir à 60 ans jusque là je dirais ça
va ça règle pas tout mais c'est une
première étape
après comment on calcule comment on peut
savoir que quelqu'un orale les 41 41 ans
et demi où on tient que la période de
périodes cotisées ça veut dire les
périodes réellement travailler plus pour
les hommes
le service national où la maternité pour
les femmes et où on prend l'ensemble des
périodes celle là plus les périodes
valider les pailles validé c'est quoi
c'est le chômage de longue durée par
exemple c'est quand vous avez un congé
parental d'éducation c'est la femme du
secteur privé qui a eu un enfant et
qu'elle de droit deux ans de validation
c'est les accidents du travail et de
l'assurance maladie au delà au delà d'un
an
donc nous ce que nous demandons c'est
comprennent l'ensemble parce que sinon
ces secousses à la différence du coût
très important tous un coût mais enfin
ce qu'on veut parce que demain d'un côté
si on reste dans la logique dite des
carrières longues type 2003 qui est
appliquée aujourd'hui on est plus dans
une logique de solidarité
on est dans une logique individuelle et
sarah en gros vous avez travaillez vous
avez cotisé vous avez le droit de mais
si vous avez été au chômage de longue
durée
vous n'êtes pas responsable ou pas
pourquoi on ne prendrait pas en compte
le chômage de longue durée
on n'a pas le coup pour moi on regarde
pas les grains à l'ancien système à vous
écouter une non c'est pas
obligatoirement l'ancien système
mais non ce n'est pas l'ancien système
en tant que tel mais si on vit on est
pour le retour à 60 ans non pas pour
tout le monde dans l'immédiat c'est pas
le décret ne porterait pas là dessus
pour au moins une catégorie de personnes
pourquoi on ne tiendrait pas compte
à ce moment là des périodes dites
valides et donc ça va être un des points
de débat je vous annonce d'ailleurs j'ai
pas les chiffres encore on les a pas en
termes de passer un point de divergence
parce que françois hollande a effectué
la dernière fois il allait mettre que je
suis motivé et on verra sur la
validation ensuite dans le débat
attendez moi je dis ça mérite discussion
s'est pas c'est pas beau c'est
d'ailleurs moi quand j'entends que vous
voulez pas de décision avant que cela
soit garanti bah oui bien sûr j'espère
enfin sinon ça compte ça démarre et
marque en termes de dialogue social
oui m'enfin référence encore une fois
sont tellement importantes sont en
matière de coût que la chaîne différence
en matière de coût minime à ce moment-là
fallait pas dire ça je suis désolé le
décret pris très vite d'arrêter en fin
de mois de juin puis bal fin du mois de
juin on a le temps de discuter avant
quand même mais les chiffres annoncés
qui est entre 120 à 150 milles je ferais
remarquer que 650 mille bénéficiaires
pardon si c'est uniquement les peuvent
cotiser sait il y en a beaucoup moins
donc qu'est ce à quoi ça correspond les
120 158 moi j'ai bien sentiment que dans
le premier projet où il y avait les 120
150 pays il y avait au moins une partie
des périodes de valider donc il va
falloir qu'on ait une explication sur
cette question là c'est pas simplement
une question d'absence de discrimination
c'est aussi une question de solidarité
est-ce qu'on raison un système de
solidarité ou est-ce qu'on glisse
progressivement comme le souhaitent
certains vers un régime individuel qui
pourrait être demain des régimes par
comptes notionnels ou par points
là je dis non nous ne serons pas
d'accord et sincère c'est la négociation
2013 oui c'est quand vous voulez pas
masser le bras faut pas passer le petit
doigt ou ou la main bon donc il est si
vous ne te si vous n'obtenez pas
satisfaction sur la validation des
trimestres
est ce que pour vous ce sera un point de
bloquer la jeune solaire déterminé je ne
suis pas là oui j'en suis pas là le
débat vous le connaissez oui les jeux je
vous dis moi comment on peut dire que
c'est 120 milles alors que si vous ne
prenez que les cotisé ces moines sont
amine donc ça veut dire selon moi qui ai
une marge de discussions
alors on verra coûtait moment on n'a pas
encore le ministre on vient juste
d'avoir le premier ministre on sait pas
avec qui on discutera de cette question
est ce que ce sera avec le premier
ministre que ce sera avec le ministre ou
la ministre du travail
donc je crois qu'on aura des réponses
assez rapides notamment sur ce dossier
est ce que vous seriez prêt à accepter
une hausse supplémentaire des
cotisations pour financer cette réforme
et tout ça ressemble à 60 ans vous êtes
avait coûté moins de monde mais
légèrement supplément vous jamais faire
je l'aurais dit oui oui mais nous
l'avons eu à 0 1 qui présideront le
moment 0,1 et patronales 0 as du côté
salarial
ça fait 0 2 sa famille
en gros 0,2 sa famille hier de recettes
supplémentaires nous n'avons jamais
fermé la porte à des augmentations aussi
nécessaires à leurs occupations et
salariés ou m'entendez nous nous
débrouiller dans les négociations de
salaires aussi un état dans une
répartition plus équitable de la valeur
ajoutée voilà ça c'est à nous de hauts
salariés aussi de récupérer d'une
manière ou d'une autre
mais attention ces derniers temps j'ai
relu des écrits salle j'étais panne et
1928 1947 1949 sur la sécurité sociale
savait ce qu'on nous explique on pourra
jamais payer etc
c'est déjà ce qu'on nous racontait
certains dans ces années-là donc et on a
fait et on a fait la retraite à 60 ans
etc
et c'est passé c'est une question
globale de politique économique ont faut
arrêter de segmenter tous les dossiers à
la retraite pôvres d'un côté d'ailleurs
moi je demanderai au gouvernement et au
premier ministre
mais enfin ça ce sera la responsable élu
premier ministre par exemple je veux pas
voir à quoi sert le haut conseil du
financement de la protection sociale
moi si on supprime ça ne me pose aucun
problème par contre qu'on recrée que le
gouvernement aurait créé une structure
de type commissariat au plan on
l'appelle comme on veut ou l'on puisse
discuter des débats de fond ce qui
n'existe plus depuis pas mal d'années à
l'abri non il ya un autre débat qui va
sortir très vite aussi c'est le coup de
pouce au smic est ce que qu'est ce que
pour vous ça signifie est ce que vous
êtes tout de suite pour une augmentation
substantielle du smic vous avez parlé de
thé parlé récemment de 1750 euros que
nous est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose
que vous voulez avoir tout de suite au
contraire vous êtes à plaindre
on a fixé on a fixé un objectif qui est
que le pour nous le smic devrait être à
80 % du salaire médian ça veut dire quoi
concrètement aujourd'hui salaire médian
est un peu plus de 1600 euros net par
mois 1 50% des français gagnent en
dessous 50% au-dessus donc c'est que ce
soit c'est en termes de référence ci
s'était appliqué aujourd'hui ça voudrait
dire qu'on aura un smic net à 1340
hommes c'est ça que ça signifie alors on
sait bien net
on sait bien que ça ne va pas se faire
d'une de comme ça en deux coups de
cuillère à pot que ça ne peut être que
progressif
en tous les cas il y avait eu six ans
qui a pas eu de coup de pouce sur le
smic
donc il faut un coup de pouce on
discutera il ya deux éléments est à la
fois le coup de pouce je ne pense pas
qu'il faille brutalement augmenté il ya
l'objectif demeure ce mois je me
souviens de 80 vous souhaitez très vite
remanger
donc attention est aussi allée grille de
salaires derrière et ce que nous
demanderons également c'est que après
l'augmentation du smic le ministre du
travail ou la ministre du travail
convoque immédiatement les commissions
mixtes paritaires dans les branches pour
que là où il ya des minimes inférieures
au smic qu'on renégocie tout de suite
pour pâques et d'écrasement d'écrasement
des grilles ça on l'a déjà fait on me
souviens comme martine aubry team du
travail ça avait été fait on avait
refait sa aussi proxitec monsieur
monsieur larcher
donc ça ça fait c'est les deux on peut
venir pas que le smic est aussi les
minima pont et puis aussi le problème de
l'indexation la délégation du smic est
ce qu'on l'a devrait ce qu'on l'index
simplement sur les prix ou est-ce qu'on
a des qs est également sur la croissance
sur trois ans et coûté positionne sur
les prix oui bien entendu il y en a
d'autres moi je tiens aussi et nous
tenons à ce que c'est l'écrit
aujourd'hui le smic est indexé aussi sur
l'augmentation de la moitié du taux de
salaire horaire
si on rajoute la croissance pourquoi pas
mais on ne peut pas remplacer la moitié
du taux de salaire horaire par la
croissance parce que ça signifie que ces
dernières années le smic augmente et
encore moins que ce qu'il augmentait
donc il y à il ya l'aspect indexation
sur les prix
il ya l'aspect par rapport à
l'augmentation générale constatée des
salaires après une période de près sont
fortes on peut rajouter mais ça peut pas
venir en déduction il a en dehors de ça
il ya aussi tous les tous les plans tous
les plans de licenciements alors c'est
vrai que pendant la période électorale a
l'impression que d'en face à tours de
plans de licenciements qui ont été gelés
vos collègues de cet été chérèque lundi
bon ça a été démenti la raison alors
voilà est ce que vous êtes maintenant
dans vous avez des remontées justement
de vos fédérations les plus diverses
justement là-dessus on a bien remonté
des inquiétudes qui se manifestent dans
différents secteurs c'est vrai dans la
métallurgie ont ça peut être vrai dans
l'automobile ça peut être vrai dans le
nucléaire dans la distribution alors
dans la distribution mes amis craignent
dans l'ensemble de la grande
distribution ils ont évoqué le chiffre
de 12 me ce qui n'est ni démenti
d'accord écoutez je suis tant mieux
non mais c'est vrai vous avez raison de
souligner que ça a été démenti carrefour
on craint 3 après trois milles s'ils
démentent très bien si ça n'a pas lieu
moi je serais le plus heureux des hommes
ceci étant c'est cellier dans la grande
distribution à différents phénomènes
c'est tassement de la consommation il ya
un impact sur l'activité dans certains
groupes ces dernières années une logique
plus financière que commercial avec du
retour sur investissement c'est le cas
de carrefour notamment un bon donc une
société bkc des craintes qui ne sont pas
qui ça fait quelques quelques mois qu'on
les a au fond cela on avait dit durant
sa campagne qu'il serait utilisé les
moyens de pression justement quand ces
plans sociaux seront présentés aux
salariés via des réponses toujours un
gouvernement quel qu'il soit a toujours
des moyens de pression sur des
entreprises ne serait-ce que ces
entreprises comme d'autres bénéficient
des aides publiques d'une manière ou
d'une autre
donc je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faudra effectivement conditionner toute
aide publique d'où qu'elle vienne au
respect de critères en matière d'emploi
ça c'est un premier élément
et après il faudra retravailler sur
toute une série d'éléments comment quand
une entreprise l'ont fait un plan social
elle fait un calcul de rentabilité c'est
comme ça qu'elle procèderait là c'est
plus rentable de et puis les
actionnaires demandent vous pouvez aussi
alourdir le coût des licenciements et
après calcul de rentabilité différent
par exemple exigé beaucoup plus en
matière de réindustrialisation de
revitalisation du site ce que nous avons
déjà proposé
vous pouvez mettre des contraintes
supplémentaires tout ça ça doit se
discuter tout comme devra être discuté
également les relations donneurs d'ordre
sous traitant est ce que c'est un des
sujets que vous voudriez voir à la
conférence sociale naquit qui c'est un
sujet de la mi juillet c'est un sujet
qui devra exécuter laquelle de priorité
cela mais je sais difficile si vous
voulez parce qu'on est confronté
aujourd'hui problème d'ensemble de
politique économique donc il ya la
question pas plus s'il ya des plans
sociaux qui font effectivement annoncées
d'ici là savaient qu il y aura des plans
sociaux puis ce sera prioritaire parce
qu'il y aura le chômage partiel il
faudra aussi de discuter de ces choses
là donc à la question de l'emploi un
mois les priorités il y en a plusieurs
et la question de l'emploi est la
question des services publics
c'est un élément essentiel à la question
salariale il ya la question également
des retraites même si elle reviendra
elle reviendra après voilà c'est les
quatre points clés tout ça en contexte
européen
allez cette conférence à ça vous
voudriez que tous les syndicats y
participent ou où vous voudriez limités
à ceux qui ont une représentativité
reconnus ou en passe de l'être
attendez pour le moment moi je considère
que ces conférences doivent être
ouvertes à ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
reconnu représentatif
donc ça signifie cinq confédérations
syndicales trois organisations
patronales
c'est ça que ça signifie que l'énergie
est indécis demain puisque les cartes
devraient être battus 2013 2014
quant à seront rebattues si d'autres
organisations perdent leur
représentativité et donne deviennent
représentative mais les autres la table
changera on peut pas édicter des règles
et ne pas les respecter
sinon on n'en sort plus loin j'ai évoqué
la prime dividendes un qui est versée
depuis l'année dernière au salarié n'est
ce pas bruno on apprend cette année que
la moitié des entreprises du cac 40 qui
ont donc bien servi leurs actionnaires
sont concernés est ce que pour vous
c'est une mesure on se souvient qu'elle
avait été lancée dans la polémique par
xavier bertrand qui doit perdurer
ecoutez-le on a dit la dernière c'était
on préfère des augmentations de salaires
c'est creil maintenant tout ce qu'on
peut prendre on va vous prouver suis
très pragmatique là dessus donc là où ça
peut être pris on le prendra mais ça
n'en valait la prime france se monte à
quelques 420 euros on connaît le nombre
de bénéfices on ne connaît pas le nombre
de bénéficiaires mais on est quand même
assez loin des bises rory on est loin
des vélos ça ne le savait ça c'est ça ne
remplace pas la négociation de salaire
dans l'entreprise en plus quand c'est un
plus bon ben si on peut décrocher un
plus on prend 1 mais c'est pas on
préfère on préfère aller sur la
négociation de salaire c'est évident des
quoi vous avez vu le modèle allemand
vous pourriez le salue aussi parce que
là les négociations salariales qui sont
menées aboutissent d66 l'augmentation du
rêve nous en france en passion pour
obtenir 6% moi je ne demande pas mieux
mais ceci étant nous aiment pas et je ne
prétends pas qui est un modèle français
mais je ne considère pas tjrs un modèle
allemand je vous rappelle quand même
qu'en allemagne il ya beaucoup de mini
jobs un très mal payés il n'y a pas de
smic
je pense que la situation sociale en
l'allemagne est plus dur qu'en france
aujourd'hui
dernière question bruno
la rgpp c'est à dire en compte toute
quiétude qui peut être fait sur le bon
fonctionnement de la fonction publique
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour que
ça s'arrête non pas l'étude proprement
dit mais le fait qu'on ne remplace pas
par exemple la fonctionnaire sur deux
qui part en mai est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que malgré tout il ya une
certaine logique est ce qu'il peut y
avoir des redondances aussi et ça c'est
assez logique que dans le fond un état
dans une période de crise soient
attentifs à la façon dont il dépense on
danse on prendra deux choses différentes
c'est quand même exister un lien mais je
veux dire la rgpp c'est y compris sur la
méthode d'abord aux lancers ingrédients
n'a pas respecté ses engagements sur
cette question là donc moins nous comme
annoncé on arrête tels que ça se faisait
là on arrête ça et on fait une
évaluation précise quelles missions
service public demain est-ce que ça ça
doit être privatisées ou pas est-ce que
moi par exemple je prends un exemple
mais je pourrais prendre des dizaines
est ce qu'il est normal aujourd'hui que
dans les abattoirs de volailles et
l'abattoir de lapin c'est ne plus les
services publics qui contrôle la qualité
de la viande parce qu'on en a plus les
moyens
c'est d'autocontrôle par les entreprises
ou verrez les jours on aura des
problèmes sanitaires barça c'est une
conséquence de la rgpp
donc faut tout mettre à plat après ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas de réforme
c'est autre chose il faut d'abord savoir
où l'on veut aller moi je veux bien
qu'on soit dans une république et je le
demande d'une république son service
public ça ne marche pas donc françois
hollande a rappelé qu'il y aurait des
embauches dans l'éducation nationale
mais il a bien précisé durant sa
campagne que les effectifs globaux de la
mention public en france n'allait pas
augmenter est ce que vous êtes satisfait
ou pas de on va voir mesure nommées la
mesure l'idée qu'on ne fasse pas grossir
le nombre de fonctionnaires dans notre
pays c'est pas c'est pas uniquement une
question de même placé mais même quand
france on verra quand il a fixé
même quand françois hollande notre
candidat annoncé 60000 j'ai dit c'est
pas une question de nombre
c'est la révision 20 le service civique
ne se résume pas une question de nom
pire même temps si on reste sur un
nombre global inchangé
il va falloir on supprime ailleurs ou
savoir où est ce que ça sera par l'effet
de l'acte iii de la décentralisation est
ce qu'il y aura peut-être j'en sais rien
des transferts vers d'autres
collectivités rurales qui ne seront pas
compensés en angoisse c'est peut-être ça
la en placement j'en sais rien merci
bruno perrine tarneaud de public sénat
arrive juste après cette enquête sur la
succession à la tête des syndical s'est
pas encore votre nom je n'appelle pas ça
va généralement le nouveau responsable
est adoubé par le titulaire sauf que
parfois ça se passe plus difficilement
avec le cas difficile on le sait de la
cgt tam tran huy se trouver un
successeur quand on est secrétaire
général d'un syndicat
c'est souvent naturel à la cfdt françois
chérèque l'a par exemple trouvé en la
personne de laurent berger et cela ravit
tout le monde
pour le sociologue jean françois amadieu
afficher le consensus c'est une habitude
chez les syndicats en fait la raison
principale qui explique pourquoi les
successions sont arrangées pourquoi n'y
a pas en général de compétition pour
l'élection d'un secrétaire général
c'est parce que dans les organisations
syndicales on privilégie l'unité ce qui
explique également que les mandats de
secrétaires généraux dure très longtemps
dans les organisations syndicales
particulièrement à force ouvrière ou à
la cgt mais justement à la cgt c'est une
nouveauté
ça coince cette année bernard thibault
verrait bien nadine prigent prendre la
tête du syndicat
alors que les fédérations lui préfère
eric aubin le très médiatique monsieur
retraites de 2010 mais pour marc blondel
ancien secrétaire général de fo
cela n'est pas nouveau mon prédécesseur
ne tenait pas du tout est ce que ce soit
moi son successeur
c'est une expression à l'intérieur de
l'organisation syndicale qui est basé
sur la démocratie qui est une démocratie
particulière pour les syndicats on va
pas solliciter les gens les citoyens de
l'extérieur pour désigner le responsable
syndical les syndicats sont
démocratiques et pour lui la situation
inédite de la cgt et même salutaire
pourtant lorsque jean claude mailly a
pris sa suite en 2004 il a fait en sorte
que cela se fasse plus en douceur et a
préféré adoubé jean claude mailly
ce que je ne voulais pas
séclier comme ce avait eu lieu lorsque
j'étais candidat
une bagarre interne qui aurait séparé
des camarades qui auraient opposé des
camarades
le choix du secrétaire général ou de la
secrétaire générale c'est important mais
le mouvement syndical a autre chose à
faire il n'a pas le temps à se consacrer
à ce genre de choses donc le conflit
ouvert
c'est bien mais surtout chez les autres
depuis 2004 jean claude mailly celui que
certains en interne traitait
d'apparatchiks est un secrétaire général
consensuelle en 2011 il a été réélu et
ne parle pas pour l'instant de son
départ limitation de la durée des
mandats des leaders syndicaux pourquoi
ça existe en politique
non ce n'est pas dans le ballet s'est
réglée par les statuts des organisations
si vous prenez les statuts du fo il n'y
a pas de limite
bon j'avais pas avoir passé je pensais
que 80 ça c'est clair mais non mais ceci
étant ce fait ces deux choses c'est à la
fois font encore en avoir envie
personnellement sinon créant deux choses
il faut qu' il faut que les nourritures
ne souhaite aussi le demande
après c'est un équilibre quoi trouver
quoi ça va j'ai toujours envie non à la
mi temps mort et lui donc voilà les
armes à mal de faire tourner il n'y a
pas que le secrétaire général dans une
organisation si vous prenez le bus
redécouvre oui c'est celui qu'on veut le
plus qui parle
oui ça va pas moi qui parle le plus avec
tous les égards mais vous savez pas en
premier bureau confédéral de fo on
maîtresses ça tourne énormément il ya
des nouveaux qui viennent d'arriver et
ccc une équipe
on travaille aussi en équipe beaucoup
dans une endroit les au renouvellement
alors qu'on sait très bien que les
syndicats ont du mal à recruter même au
niveau des entreprises
c'est pas aussi aussi simple que ça non
non car je fais partie du débat mais
vous savez le taux de syndicalisation en
france on peut dire qu'il n'est pas
assez élevé il a b c etc
mais il n'a jamais été très élevé c'est
lié aussi à la manière dont nous négocié
dans notre pays est maintenant moi je
veux bien qu'on ait des responsables qui
part dans les départements etc
franchement il n'ya jamais de problème
pour trouver le successeur alors une
première
sion avec notre partenaire orange vous
pouvez poser des questions à jean-claude
mailly sur votre application
tvcheck sur les mobiles orange à la
poupe qui vous demandera pas été trop
dur de succéder à marc blondel
non non franchement franchement non bon
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec lui avait
auparavant ou s il en résumé on peut
dire vous lui devez un peu toute votre
carrière
non non non c'est non mais attendez
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
c'est pas lui qui m'a demandé de le
remplacer c'est moi qui était candidat
moment donné c'est lui qui vous a fait
rentrer à force ouvrière et m'a proposé
de venir se rabattant nassim a proposé
quand il est rentré lui au bureau
confédéral de fo il avait eu comme
responsabilité le secteur économique et
cherchait quelqu'un qui avait fait des
études d'économie et qui était militant
il faut que c'était mon cas voilà donc
c'est comme ça que je suis mieux
travailler je vais vous faire une ou des
bus dans ma tête c'était pour deux trois
ans ouais bon je vais faire ça de trois
ans et en même temps eh ben ça fait
presque trente ans voilà donc c'est un
virus
ouais quel plaisir personnel en empire
c'est pas c'est un non c'est pas ça se
situe pas en terme de plaisir personnel
s'est constitué oui non mais attendez si
c'était la galère je vois arriver
non mais je mets en même temps ce le
syndicaliste c'est quelque chose de très
concret les plus beaux souvenirs qu'on a
c'est quand on a réussi à décrocher
quelque chose qu'on a réussi à régler
tel ou tel dossier c'est ça les plus
beaux de plus beau souvenir qu'on a vous
n'avez jamais eu envie de vous mettre au
service d'une entreprise autre que le
syndicalisme moi c'est pas une
entreprise non pour moment non je moi ça
fait très longtemps que je milite avant
de gémellité quand j'étais jeune
également donc non moi je considère que
pour être militant il faut être belle à
un moment donné refuser les injustices
san état d'esprit aussi au départ après
comment vous pouvez réaliser ça j'ai pu
moi le réaliser dans militantisme pu
faire du militantisme politique j'ai
choisi militantisme syndical et pour le
moment ça me va très bien
ce soutien c'est un peu aussi un
héritage familial oui monsieur mais ça
c'est pas forcément héréditaire mais
dans le cadre de ma famille williams
ça fait plusieurs générations de
militants avec qui plus est il faut mais
ça c'est pas automatique mais je crois
qu'on surnommait même votre grand père
le jour je reste du nord il avait 2,2
surnom le jaurès des mineurs et le
deuxième sur non c'est le père des
polonais parce que vous voyez déjà au
19e siècle
il s'était battu avec pas tout seul avec
ses amis pour que les mineurs polonais
les mêmes droits des mineurs français
donc des dossiers qu'on avait déjà et
plus l'assiette
marc blondel à un petit regret vous
concernant et trouve que vous n'avez pas
toujours assez le sens de la formule du
bon mot est ce que c'est parce que vous
avez une personnalité peut-être un peu
moins affirmé que lui on est différent
où vous jouez un peu moi le jeu
immédiatement on est différent moi je
considère que c'est pas parce que je
suis devenu secrétaire général que je
dois changer je pense est resté ce que
j'étais avant bon là on a il a un
tempérament et on fonctionne très
différemment l'un de l'autre
bon bah blondel s'était pas bergeron et
moi je suis pas blonde elle de ce point
de vue là tempéraments sont différents
je n'ai pas envie de changer françois
hollande c'est un homme politique que
vous côtoyez depuis longtemps vous étiez
ce matin à la passation de pouvoirs à
son investiture à l'elysée on a beaucoup
dit que c'était un homme qui n'arrivait
pas toujours à trancher est ce que c'est
ainsi que vous le voyez vous non je
pense que c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a peut-être pas affirmer directement
les choses qui va essayer de trouver des
solutions c'est plus comme ça que je le
vois que enfin dans les contacts que
j'avais pu avoir avec lui notamment
quand il était premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
enfin si vous et on n'arrive pas à ce
type de responsabilité et président de
la république quand on sait pas tranché
c'est pas possible on le découvre à ses
secrets aujourd'hui c'est jacques attali
qui nous en parler sur ce plateau la
semaine dernière et c'est vrai qu'il a
tenu un peu secret toutes ces décisions
lors de cette transition de pouvoir vous
connaissiez vous cette facette de cette
perte de sa personnalité
oui oui je suis parce que je suis pas
surpris par le fait qu'ils ne disent pas
comme ça toutes les choses bah écoute et
qu'on aura demain la composition du
gouvernement maintenant on bon ton nom
circule etc
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de rumeurs en
la matière il n'y a pas beaucoup de
choses pour l'instant non non il n'y a
pas de mensonge à demain mais à la
limite c'est peut-être pas plus mal ça
on verra inchangé de nicolas sarkozy qui
lui jouait beaucoup plus cartes sur
table oui mais avec oui mais
c'était c'était du direct c'était
parfois parfois du frontal également
quels souvenirs vous garderez de
certains échanges que vous avez pu avoir
avec lui un bain un dossier qu'on avait
pu régler qui m'avait sur lequel moi
j'avais été satisfait c'était quand on
nous avions obtenu par exemple que quand
il ya eu les évolutions chez eads que
les filiales reste 100% aux ads sage on
l'avait obtenue on avait obtenu avec lui
savait c'était quelqu'un qui sait un
avocat de formation donc et un dossier
on essaie de le régler au cas par cas et
s'il y avait un problème à sennecey va
discuter avec la cgt puisqu'elle était
première organisation
c'est un problème chez airbus c'est faux
première nation donc ont discuté
ensemble
bon donc ça c'est un des bons souvenirs
après il ya eu des des contacts à risque
oui mais en même temps sur le dossier
retraites c'est quand même un mauvais
souvenir sur la représentativité j'ai un
mauvais souvenir également sur la
manière dont les choses se sont faites
ah bon il n'était pas tout seul dans sa
passion oui où
c'était pas sa spécialité le social
c'était son conseiller à l'époque mais
raymond soubie était son conseiller à
l'elysée où je sais pas si ça a payé
ah oui pardon non bon avec avec le recul
mais je vais déjà dit mais je crois
qu'il lui a fait faire des bêtises
comme quoi par exemple attendez on ne
fonctionne plus dans les années 2000
comme dans les années 70 et monsieur
soubie dans le mode de raisonnement est
un homme des années 70 et notre 900 une
autre question avec notre partenaire
orange et l'application eyetv tchèque
sur le blocage des prix les sens c'était
un engagement de campagne de françois
hollande
en raison de la baisse des prix de
l'essence le gouvernement ne va sans
doute pas prendre de décisions de
blocage pour l'instant est ce que c'est
justifié comme raisons selon vous oui
écoutez si on assiste effectivement si
ça se poursuit à une baisse du prix de
l'essence à peu retardé mais nous on a
une revendication qui est autre c'est
l'instauration de primes transports
qu'on avait obtenu de l'ancien
gouvernement assure le transport
collectif et pas partout sur le
transport individuel on a obtenu je
prends une entreprise comme danone par
exemple où on a réussi à négocier
l'équivalent un peu plus de 400 euros
par an pour les gens qui sont obligés
d'aller bosser avec la voiture donc il
ya deux manières de régler si le prix de
l'essence baisse c'est pas utile de
bloquer tout de suite mais il ya aussi
il ya de plus en plus des salariés qui
sont obligés de prendre
des négociations ça passe heureusement
d'entrée on peut être oui on peut mais
une loi pourrait obliger au moins parce
qu'elle existe après on négocie
entreprise par entreprise en avait déjà
discuté pendant la campagne avec les
équipes de france a été évoquée mais
dans une campagne dit quelles sont vos
revendications ils écoutent mais c'est
maintenant qu'on aura les latences un
autre engagement de campagne françois
hollande c'était de revoir les salaires
des patrons pour les grandes entreprises
publiques visiblement ça va être quand
même un peu plus compliqué que ça
puisque les contrats sont en cours on
peut pas les bons en tout cas ça va être
compliqué à faire oui mais je pense que
l'idée est bonne nous on est dans le
cadre européen syndicalement on avait
dit faut limiter de 1,20 et le projet
c'est le produit s'était repris
d'ailleurs d'accord alors je sais bien
que ça se fait pas aidé contre un abri
des problèmes juridiques haute mais je
vous considère quand même qu'on pourrait
réduire réduire l'éventail parce qu'en
plus il ya pas que la rémunération et
tout ce qui va à côté allez bonne nuit
fais stock options etc
ça fait partie des éléments qui ont
conduit à ce que ce sentiment
d'injustice sociale se développe c'est
évident la rolls règles ou en limitant
d'une manière ou d'une autre il ya deux
émanent d'un élément pour régler c'est
par la réforme fiscale
on peut aussi par la fiscalité
redistribuer différemment donc taxer
plus fortement les 75 % sur les revenus
supérieurs à 1 million d'euros somme
chaque fois je le dis ça me choque pas
mais c'est pas une réforme fiscale ça la
réforme fiscale elle doit être beaucoup
plus important selon moi elle doit
redonner à l'impôt sur le revenu sa
vraie place
l'impôt le plus juste c'est l'impôt sur
le revenu vous n'avez pas commenter bien
sûr les affaires des autres syndicats on
avait tout à l'heure avec tom traduit le
petit rappel des transitions qui sont en
train de s'opérer actuellement et
notamment à la cgt et à la cfdt était
plus difficilement
qu'est ce que vous diriez que bernard
thibault est en train de rater sa sortie
écoutez on verra à la fin du comment ça
se fait mais je sais pas moi j'ai pas
dans le savez déjà là aujourd'hui je
suis pas
ces tensions ce qui brille à la
mi-journée au bas comme tout le monde je
lis jaune les journaux mais si ça l'est
dans ce genre de choses c'est valable
pour le syndicat comme pour autre chose
quand vous dites que vous partez vous
avez déjà moins de poids bah oui c'est
parce que tout le monde pense à celui
qui est aussi celle qui va vous
remplacez donc il a peut-être parler
trop tôt c'est pour ça que vous même
vous avez bien ancrée pas jusqu'à 80 ans
mais on a un gars doux amer que je fais
bien lent villenvie merci à vous merci
bonsoir à tous
tout le matin à 8h15 guillaume durand et
gilles leclair reçoivent une
personnalité politique dans en route
vers la présidentielle d'élection
présidentielle de 2012 en tout état de
cause sera extraordinairement difficile
c'est qu'il y ait un candidat de serre
et la jolie et l'adversaire c'est la
broye le grand courant du centre en
france a le droit et le devoir d'être
présent dans cette élection il faut
faire ce que marine prennent à 10 en
partenariat avec radio classique
en route vers la présidentielle tous les
matins à 20h15 en direct sur public
sénat l'actualité politique version
numérique
sur les quinze jours je vous propose de
prendre le pouls des débats qui agitent
la planète web de décoder les stratégies
des candidats sur le net
en deux mots je serai tout ouïe tweets
pour rendre compte de vos conversations
citoyenne sur les réseaux sociaux la
politique cionet jeudi à 22h30 sur
public sénat
comment la série peut-elle s'extirper de
l'engrenage de la violence
bachar ne pourra pas faire taire la
société syrienne à l'heure d'internet il
ne peut plus empêcher l'opposition de
parler pour comprendre les enjeux de ce
drame politique et humain ce
documentaire des mails les rouages du
système mis en place par le clan assad
de père en fils d'hafez à bachar
hafez el-assad pouvait emprisonné
pendant vingt ans les gens sans que
personne n'en sache rien
cela n'est plus possible aujourd'hui le
fait que cela dure depuis si longtemps
cela ne veut pas dire que la population
accepte tout cela ou qu'elles s'y est
habitué le crépuscule des assad samedi à
15h15 sur public sénat du jour les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
mais c'est une aberration
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs
mon nom est jacques khalid de l'habitat
ou vers minuit dans une cité
il lui trouve bien je me souviens quand
je suis arrivé j'avais trois choses dans
ma musette et que je n'ai pas abandonné
pour nourrir mes interventions
puis combat auquel j'ai participé avec
mes collègues
la première c'est que j'étais maire
d'aubervilliers et que c'est une ville
qui ne vous laisse pas indifférent elle
vous marque pour toujours c'est une
ville populaire brut mettant brrr ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième bon
j'avais été ministre c'est une
expérience la santé le travail mais je
pense surtout à la santé on peut naître
dans des milieux qu'on ne connaît pas
résultats à prendre les combats mieux et
puis la troisième chose il ya un appel
qui avait été signé par 174
intellectuels et artistes pour que je
sois sénateurs schena c'est aussi là
semblait intéressante parce que je
trouve qu'on a plus le temps de
travailler et précisément quand j'étais
ministre j'en ai aperçu qu'on aller plus
en profondeur
oui la greffe parle dans la rue devenu
nouvel espace public
la greffe parle comme une insurrection
mentale d'humanité la greffe parle et
récuse les solutions régressive libéral
et étatiste la greffe parle elle et le
peuple dans sa dignité sa diversité sa
responsabilité
la greffe parle pose des questions
humaines plus profonde encore que les
revendications déclaré et réclament tout
simplement la vie
c'était en plein en pleine grande
tourmente
et quand je vois ce que j'utilisais il
ya une vraie hier qu'il a vraiment
condensé quand elle a dit au gré d'une
interview d'un journaliste tant que
l'argent dominera le monde
il nous en manquons et je crois que
c'est ça la grande question
elle existe c'est ce jour-là elle
continue d'exister et dans une ampleur
bien plus grande actuellement mais
malheureusement et j'espère
provisoirement c'est l'argent qui dirige
l'argent caché et l'argent invisible et
ils n'ont aucune commisération aucune
balle en jeu c'était 2 comme monsieur
juppé est bien rentré son projet
destructeur quoi et on a gagné
enfin révision parce que je me mets dans
ceux qui se battaient mais ils ont gagné
ce qui fait que c'est toujours possible
c'est complexe mais c'est toujours
possible
nous devions débattre des profonds
problèmes de banlieue
après le conseil des ministres
exceptionnel de lundi ce débat a été
remplacé par l'examen d'une loi
d'exception ultra sécuritaire qui vise à
enchaîner toute espèce de liberté
en exagérant toute espèce de danger ce
n'est pas l'ordre dans la république
c'est la république de l'ordre nous
sommes contre votre loi vous ne déclarez
pas la guerre à la pauvreté mais aux
pauvres la banlieue mérite tout autre
chose
excuse moi il reste sarkozy en face il
était ministre de l'intérieur il
écoutait mai et appelle les parties
donc je n'ai pas eu de réponse venu de
lui mais il était là et il était là
après avoir fait sa visite de la
courneuve et avoir parlé du karcher et
il était là après avoir fait sa visite à
argenteuil et avoir parlé des racailles
ou autre vocabulaire
c'est symptomatique quand la réaction
veut taper l insulte le peuple dans sa
diversité
d'ailleurs on dit les gens ou des
douleurs vives une ville
moi je connais des gens de paris qui
viendraient pas